one of the key buzzwords these days the
common prescription for a happy life we
are told is learn to be more present
learn to be in the moment right David
Lentz and once described anxiety is
essentially temporal dislocation anxiety
means you're not here now you're
concerned about the future you're
anxious about the past and those things
become like turbulence for the mind
making your flight through life an
annoyingly terrifying one constantly
shaking up and down with your
inner peace and so it's interesting
right because if we're told that
learning to be present is the way in
which we may find peace and fulfillment
we're actually being asked to betray our
biological hardware see what separates
us from other animals in the animal
kingdom is that we come equipped with
this neocortical hardware this neocortex
right and what that does is it allows us
to think in abstraction to take
ourselves out of the moment and conceive
potentially of delightful future
possibilities pick the most amazing one
and pull the present forward to meet
that possibility or capacity to imagine
to create is a byproduct of our
sophisticated state-of-the-art latest
evolutionary model neocortical hardware
but it is that same mental capacity that
same piece of hardware that betrays us
once we satiate our basic needs right
it's like okay you got a job you paid
the bills you're secure in your physical
safety but this neocortical hardware is
still thinking about the future still
evaluating scenarios still assessing
risks we are the descendants of the most
neurotic humans of the past the ones
that were constantly afraid the ones
that were constantly assessing threats
and feeling anxious and and in flooring
those threats we we've inherited this
hardware that has made us in some ways
achieve the impossible soar through the
sky transcend space-time and mine
collapse geography with our
technological mediation we are as gods
and yet our minds betray us yet 70
million Americans have are medicated for
anxiety we live in the safest time in
all of human history yet we can't sleep
at night from the amount of anxiety that
we're dealing with depression and
anxiety at leaves mental illnesses from
carrying the burden of having to figure
out what to do with our lives and a
world that doesn't tell us exactly what
to do right I mean it's like society
might offer a map or a model of how to
live but most of us have a sneaking
suspicion that nobody really knows what
they're talking about and so what do we
do
aside from fetching water and chopping
wood and having kids and making love
what the hell do we do and I'm not
saying I have the answer to that
question but I know that it doesn't come
just from being present but perhaps from
some kind of marriage some kind of
synergistic harmony between learning to
occasionally be present be here now be
in the moment but also acknowledge that
we are not just human beings we are
human becoming and we need to constantly
be
probing the perimeters of the possible
and bringing new spaces and
possibilities into being and so I think
it's I think it's a marriage of both and
I think that finding balance between
those two forces I think take us the
next leap forward
you
[Music]